let's go to the Discord Lines phone
lines call them what you want
let's hear from the people in the
audience at the end of the day the most
important people to the show
uh davidpackman.com Discord is where you
can find the Discord and let's start
today with Diego from Jacksonville
Florida Diego welcome what's on your
mind today
Diego welcome what is on your mind today
and Diego is gone let's go next to Paul
from St Louis Paul from St Louis welcome
to the program
hi David can you hear me I can hear you
fine my friend beautiful
um so I had a quick comment about your
interview with Mike Lindell and I know
we've beaten this to death already sure
um but
I showed that interview to a friend of
mine and he insisted that Mike Lindell
instead of being just uh unable to come
up with his own thoughts uh and trying
to like get these numbers from uh what
was it Minnesota Wisconsin I think in
the interview I did with him yeah yeah
so instead of
um that he's just being dishonest and I
said I don't know I feel like he really
is a True Believer and believes what
he's saying
um but what I would like to see if you
actually do interview him again in the
future yeah uh is communicate with him
ahead of time listen I might ask you
about this I would like to I'd like for
you to have those numbers in front of
you
um so that we can actually discuss and
like really drill down into what these
numbers are telling us in a practical
sense it's basically impossible the the
community so that would make sense like
in a logical planet where where the
communication with him and his team
makes sense but based on the way that
these interviews get booked and what the
communications like that is an
impossibility it's not an unreasonable
suggestion you're making a completely
reasonable suggestion it'll just never
happen the way that it's it's a miracle
he even ends up in front of the camera
at the time roughly at the time we've
agreed on
uh yeah I I think that is very fair uh I
do think that in that interview he was
the most Lucid I think I've ever seen
him
well you know I I you're right in a
sense but there's a question of okay he
sounds articulate and Lucid but at the
same time if he's literally just making
the things up as he goes along it's not
particularly it's not real Lucidity and
if he's delusionally believing these
things that's also not really Lucid I
think what you mean is he just sounded
coherent yes that's exactly what I mean
right right no I agree with you he did
sound more coherent although the things
coming out of his mouth made no sense
uh okay one more quick question is there
um a time slot that you are booking for
him or is it his people telling you okay
this is how much time that he has
so I was I our producer Pat handled the
logistics if I recall correctly the
interview was roughly at the normal time
we propose so I I it seems to me that we
kind of proposed the time and he agreed
to it okay yeah because I was wondering
if there's a way to like you know
instead of like really just let him
find those numbers and just sit there
until he
comes up with them you know yeah I mean
you're everything you're saying makes
sense it's just like when you're
actually producing a show it things
don't necessarily work out where that
that's plausible
sure okay well that's all I had David
all right my friend thank you very much
yeah I know a lot of people with a lot
of questions about the logistics of the
uh pillow interview and others I want to
tell you about something I use every day
because it simplifies my life I don't
have hours to mathematically plan every
meal or take multiple different
supplements and vitamins to make sure
I'm getting exactly what I want to get
every single day and the solution is our
sponsor athletic greens product ag1 I've
been taking ag1 for over a year it's
just great it's just one small scoop of
ag1 in the morning I get 75 vitamins
minerals probiotic all from whole food
sources it's what I want it's no more
it's no less it's no extraneous stuff
making wild claims I drink it straight
with water because I like the taste you
can put it in a smoothie or juice or a
shake it's just simple ag1 is a
sustainable routine because it's just
one scoop in the morning takes one
minute once a day I know I'm covered in
getting what I want I can really be sure
that I am properly nourishing my body
with the things I'm trying to get that's
the most important part athletic greens
knows I'm a vitamin D guy I've talked
about in the winter I take vitamin D to
make up for the lack of sun exposure I
take that every day as well I've
mentioned it on the show and so athletic
greens is giving you a free year of
vitamin D and five free travel packs
with your first purchase when you go to
athleticgreens.com Pacman the link is
down below